egon krage lieber eigentlich ein
zufriedener mensch seine pension an
einer münchner ausfallstraße sein ganzes
glück bis vor einigen wochen die korona
kam das ging alles abwärts in den
letzten zwei monaten habe ich keinen
einzigen gehabt canas galette ist event
managerin mit herz und tutin sommer ist
sie eigentlich auf festivals unterwegs
mit dem virus kann das finanzielle aus
sehr bitter also und massiv auch immer
nicht ganz klar wie massiv das ist zwei
menschen von vielen tausend die derzeit
allein in münchen durch corona
finanziell in die krise stürzen
das betrifft alle bevölkerungsgruppen
die arbeitnehmer aber auch die
selbstständigen gerade die kleineren
trifft hier gewaltig seit 54 jahren
existiert die kleine pension schon die
mutter von herrn kragl hat hier
vermietet 14 zimmer 37 euro die nacht
ideal für handwerker auf montage
80 prozent belegung in guten zeiten und
jetzt leer stand ich habe keinen anruf
bekommen keine mails bekommen keine
bestellung es ist nichts das heißt das
leben sie im moment wo man sparen müssen
und wie sieht es mit den art wie lange
reicht es wenn ich nur davon 1 anja
ja es ist so schlimm
knapp 4000 euro miete muss der
68-jährige pro monat zahlen
sein mietvertrag läuft noch etwa
anderthalb jahre
er könnte zwar vorzeitig aussteigen doch
die hohe ablöse kann er nicht bezahlen
ehrlich gesagt ich habe meine gedanken
noch nie so richtig sortieren ein schock
ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll
das ist wirklich ich weiß es nicht
wenn es gut lief denn hat kenia skelett
als veranstalterin auch richtig gut
verdient wacken rock am ring die großen
festivals waren ihre welt doch von einem
tag auf den anderen brechen der
51-jährigen alle aufträge weg dann nicht
die cousine und die freundinnen gekommen
werden und die schwester natürlich auch
die gesagt hat ich gebe euch ein
bisschen geld und ich lade euch was und
das auch egal wann es zurückkommt dann
wer die mittel nicht mehr zauber gewesen
seit kurzem haben sie und ihr mann jay
einen 450 euro job packen öko kisten für
den versand es ist natürlich ein ganz
anderes leben finanziell bewegt man sich
in ganz anderen sphären sagt man
überlegt sich wie es beim nächsten tag
existenzsorgen die auch ihren mann jay
umtreiben geboren in london lebt der
seit 20 jahren in deutschland der
musiker und dj ist europaweit
aufgetreten in angesagten clubs seit
märz habe er rund 95 prozent seiner
einkünfte verloren wenn ich auf meine
bankauszüge schaue dann sehe ich seit
wochen nur noch eine null
ich habe künstler hilfe von wahlen
bekommen dafür bin ich auch sehr dankbar
aber das ging weg für die schulden die
sich in den letzten wochen angesammelt
haben 3000 euro gab es von der künstler
hilfe neben den schulden müssen miete
lebenshaltungskosten und und und bezahlt
werden das ersparte ist nahezu
aufgebraucht
fühlen sie sich arm ja das also ich
fühle mich arm an möglichkeiten und bin
aber auch arm
monitor aber es ist schwierig das sich
einzugestehen
die meisten hier haben durch ko ohne
ihre jobs verloren studenten
selbstständige aus den
unterschiedlichsten branchen
wir haben viele mitarbeiter gewonnen aus
unterschiedlichen abteilungen
unterschiedlichen firmen die korona
bedingt nicht mehr arbeiten können wir
haben sehr viele aus der
veranstaltungsbranche sehr viele aus der
gastronomie sehr viele studenten arm
durch corona das böse erwachen kommt für
viele erst in ein paar monaten wenn die
rücklagen aufgebraucht sein so der vdk
umso wichtiger sei es die korona
überbrückungshilfen auszubauen muss ja
genau hingucken dass die gesellschaft
hier sich nicht weiter spaltet und dass
das oben und unten hier noch größer wird
die kluft die wächst dann noch weiter
und es müssen mehr hilfen auch für
selbständige für kleinere selbstständige
gewährt werden
das gefühl hinten runterzufallen von der
politik nicht gesehen zu werden hat auch
daniela man seit 20 jahren führt sie ein
reisebüro unterstützt von ihrer
schwester und jetzt muss sie erleben
dass große unternehmen mit starker lobby
bevorzugt werden hilfen auch in der
reisebranche nicht jeden erreichen
die soll alle logik ihre hilfen kriegen
wenn viel weggebrochen und besonders
auch keiner kaputt gehen aber und die
wollen gar nicht gesehen
ihr reisebüro in berlin hohenschönhausen
ist eigentlich ein solides unternehmen
vergangenes jahr dachte die 50-jährige
noch was sollen wir passieren das
geschäft läuft
daniela man konnte den umsatz pro
urlauber von durchschnittlich 500 auf
2000 euro steigern hatte viele stammen
konnten
doch seit fünf monaten verdient sie so
gut wie kein geld mehr
wir haben wirklich mit absage und
stornierungen und rückabwicklung und
wiesen beantragen mehr zu tun als mit
reisen verkaufen wenn wir jetzt pro tag
eine reise verkaufen da freuen wir uns
die boller also das ja früher waren seit
zehn reisen am tag oder 9000 euro
soforthilfe hat sie bekommen
die sind für mieter und andere laufende
kosten drauf gegangen das größte problem
sei aber dass die reiseveranstalter ihre
provision zurückfordern
von denen die reisebüros eigentlich
leben dann kam die absage konnte doch
nicht reisen müssen wieder zurückzahlen
also es kommt nichts rein aber das minus
soll sich ohne ende auf deshalb darum
sind reisebüros auch mal so eine
besondere branche also die habe ich
einfach nur zu gemacht und es auf null
und wir arbeiten den ganzen tag voll 4 -
und nicht nur das viele
reiseveranstalter reagieren kaum auf
mails oder anrufe aus dem reisebüro und
wird jedoch mal ein urlaub gebucht geht
es drunter und drüber
teilweise kriegen wir sind die
veranstalter nicht mal dass die flügel
stufen sind oder das hotel noch nicht
geöffnet hat wir kriegen ganz normale
reise unternahm flug hotel mit allem
drum und dran so und wenn bäume gucken
wir rein nix ist hotel gar nicht
geöffnet
der ärger der kunden landet auch noch
hier im reisebüro jedes zweite in berlin
wird wahrscheinlich nicht überleben
befürchtet die industrie und
handelskammer in der gastronomie sind
die prognosen genau so schlecht
es droht eine insolvenzwelle kasten weil
man weiß was das heißt er hat bereits
eine insolvenz hinter sich
der betriebsleiter der altberliner weiß
wer stube wagte mit seinem team 2009 10
einen neuanfang
das lokal in berliner nikolaiviertel
schrieb schwarze zahlen
bis zum 15 märz da musste die weiß wie
stur beschließen
warum sämtliche aggregate strom
technischer natur abgeschaltet
nichtsdestotrotz bleiben grundsätzliche
betriebskosten wie ein reststrom die
mieten wie versicherungen wie klima
gebühren die berufsgenossenschaft uns
weiter bleiben bestehen gemein versuchte
weil man das lokal erstmals wieder zu
öffnen macht dann nach zehn tagen aber
erneut dicht so sagen darf beschissen 14
prozent des umsatzes nur generieren
konnten und dafür brauche ich noch nicht
mal ob er glos nicht anschalten weil das
kostet mehr strom und sich auch daran
höheren umsatz generieren kann
nicht noch einmal soll das lokal in die
schulden rutschen
darüber wacht auch der
insolvenzverwalter der device bierstube
seit einem jahr unterstützt regelmäßig
kontrolliert er die zeit
das ist so wenn die
betriebswirtschaftlichen auswertung da
habe ich auch immer sind vergleich zum
vormonat oder zum letzten jahr das ist
eigentlich wichtig und wenn ich dann
sehe bei den einnahmen dass es
erhebliche einbrüche gibt dann kann ich
nachfragen gerade jetzt viele
gastronomen hatten es schon vor corona
schwer über die runden zu kommen und
alle kosten zu decken
das virus hat ihn quasi endgültig den
stecker gezogen
gastronomie aus meiner erfahrung ich
habe einiges abgewickelt die sind immer
so hart an der kante das ist nie so
richtig kostendeckend oder vielleicht
mal gerade drüber es gibt ganz wenige
die da gut wirklich mit umgehen können
also das wird sehr schwierig werden auch
für die weiße stube hilfe vom staat
bekommt das lokal nicht weil es im
insolvenzverfahren steckt aber es gibt
einen neuen investor und seit august ist
das lokal wieder geöffnet muss beweisen
dass es auch in krisenzeiten läuft wir
werden zu kämpfen haben aber ich gehe
davon aus dass wir doch dafür braucht es
touristen die nur langsam zurück kehren
sie machen fast 70 prozent des umsatzes
aus noch wichtiger ist aber dass die
infektionsraten nicht weiter steigen
kommt die zweite welle wir müssen wieder
alle zu machen
dann habe ich ein problem dann wird
liquidiert eine zweite welle wäre
wahrscheinlich auch das ende für daniela
manz reisebüro für sich selbst hat die
50-jährige jetzt hat vier beantragt aber
sie will nicht aufgeben weiter um ihr
geschäft kämpfen glaubt sie dass ihr es
retten können
ja das war zum beispiel die erste was
meine schwester sagte sie gesagt habe
doch so schaffen wir natürlich schaffen
ist das für mich jetzt immer schon alles
geschafft
sein leben habe er sich ganz anders
vorgestellt sagt herr klagelied der
besitzer der pension
jahrzehntelang hat der 68-jährige hart
gearbeitet
ich habe normal gelebt ich habe meine
wohnung bezahlt ich hab nur mal gelebt
meine versicherung bezahlt ich habe
leben können
also ich musste mir sorgen machen wenn
ich zum tengelmann bin was ich kaufe
jetzt kündigt die preise ja es hat sich
alles sehr gern wird gegen seine angst
nimmt heck ra die tabletten zur
beruhigung wie er sagt seine
zukunftsplanung durch corona vernichtet
ich hab mir und arbeiten aufhören
gedacht
es macht mir spaß ich arbeite gerne mit
leuten aber dass das ist alles so kommt
das ist natürlich jetzt dass das jetzt
alles so kommt auch georg veit hätte
sich das in seinen schlimmsten
albträumen nicht vorstellen können
georg veit ist lichtdesigner große und
kleine bühnen seien mädchen aber
bregenzer festspiele aufwendige
theaterprojekte oder events er ist
erfolgreich finanziell ist es natürlich
ein komplettes desaster also die
einnahmen die ich jetzt bekommen haben
sind auf null
ich habe seit seit mit dem märz keine
einzige rechnung geschrieben und da geht
es natürlich um 4 5 stellige summe die
meisten projekte im in und ausland
weggebrochen
alle veranstaltungen bis auf weiteres
abgesagt im moment sagt der 52 jährige
lebe er von ersparten nur wie lange noch
wenn es jetzt das restliche jahr so
weitergeht dann ist es natürlich auch
alles weg wenige werden einen langen
atem haben
der kulturbereich gerät als erstes in
die krise und wird als letztes wieder
herauskommen so seine große sorge dass
tatsächlich wenn es so weitergeht diese
branche nicht mehr existieren wird oder
oder nur noch ein ganz
teilen eine ganze branche gerät ins
wanken
eine entwicklung die auch tanja und ihr
mann jay befürchten wegen corona sind
alle auftritte des djs bis auf weiteres
abgesagt worden
[Musik]
das stresst mich total weil
normalerweise planst du ein vierteljahr
im voraus aber seit corona kann ich
keinerlei pläne machen nichts
es gibt keinerlei aussichten für die
zukunft ihre stammkneipe die szene bar
corleone muss corona bedingt bis auf
weiteres geschlossen bleiben um nicht
völlig ins leere zu laufen legt die
hierauf auch um seine freunde in der bar
zu unterstützen
wir haben alltägliche diesen live stream
um halt
auch praktische aufmerksam zu machen auf
unsere situation und spenden zu sammeln
und es gibt keine einnahmen es gibt gar
nichts
und keiner weiß wann sich diese
miserable lage wieder verändert
zu der finanziellen belastung kommt eine
extreme psychische anspannung noch dazu
zum ersten mal in meinem leben habe ich
keinerlei perspektive
es ist eine leere in meinem leben mit
der ich nie gerechnet hätte ich habe
mich von einem tag für münster
düstere aussichten keine einzelfälle
hunderttausenden in deutschland geht es
wie den menschen in diesem film
man darf diese menschen nicht vergessen
nicht nur die großen unternehmen denken
die luft haben saß und dann man muss ja
wirklich an die gastronomen hoteliers an
die selbständigen und auch die menschen
die in der kulturszene arbeiten wenden
denn sie alle sind unverschuldet in die
korona krise geraten und ein ende ist
für sie noch lange nicht in sicht